WAY THEY LOOK
>> Bill: HANG ON ONE MOMENT,
TIM.
BERNIE SANDERS IS BEGINNING HIS
REMARKS NOW.
BURLINGTON, VERMONT.
>> NO KNOWS WHAT THE NUMBER OF
FATALITIES MAY END UP BEING.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO MAY GET
ILL AND WE ALL HOPE THAT NUMBER
WILL BE AS LOW AS POSSIBLE.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO FACE THE
TRUTH AND THAT IS THAT THE
NUMBER OF CASUALTIES MAY
ACTUALLY BE EVEN HIGHER THAN
WHAT THE EXPERIENCED IN WORLD
WAR II.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE HAVE A MAJOR,
MAJOR CRISIS AND WE MUST ACT
ACCORDINGLY.
THEREFORE, IT IS AN ABSOLUTE
MORAL IMPERATIVE THAT OUR
RESPONSE AS A GOVERNMENT, AS A
SOCIETY, AS A BUSINESS COMMUNITY
AND AS INDIVIDUAL CITIZENS MEET
THE ENORMITY OF THIS CRISIS.
AS PEOPLE STAY OR WORK FROM HOME
AND ARE DIRECTED TO QUARANTINE,
IT WILL BE EASY FOR US TO FEEL
LIKE WE ARE ALL ALONE.
I’M WORKING AT HOME.
NOT AT MY HOUSE.
OFFICE.
OR THAT WE MUST ONLY WORRY ABOUT
OURSELVES AND THINK THAT
EVERYBODY ELSE SHOULD FEND FOR
THEMSELVES.
BUT, IN MY VIEW, THAT WOULD BE A
TRAGIC AND DANGEROUS MISTAKE.
IF THERE EVER WAS A TIME IN THE
MODERN HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY
WHEN WE ARE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER, IT IS THAT MOMENT.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR SOLIDARITY.
NOW IS THE TIME TO COME TOGETHER
WITH LOVE AND COMPASSION AND FOR
ALL, INCLUDING THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY
WHO WILL FACE THIS PANDEMIC FROM
A HEALTH PERSPECTIVE OR FACE IT
FROM AN ECONOMIC PERSPECTIVE.
IF OUR NEIGHBOR OR CO-WORKER
GETS SICK, WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO BECOME SICK.
IF OUR NEIGHBOR LOSES HIS OR HER
JOB, THEN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
SUFFERS AND WE MAY LOSE OUR
JOBS.
WE ARE IN THIS TOGETHER.
IF DOCTORS AND NURSES AND
MEDICAL PERSONNEL DO NOT HAVE
THE EQUIPMENT AND THE TRAINING
AND THE CAPACITY THEY NEED RIGHT
NOW, PEOPLE WE KNOW MAY
UNNECESSARILY FACE ADDITIONAL
ILLNESS AND EVEN DEATH.
WE ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS TIME OF
INTERNATIONAL CRISIS, IT IS
CLEAR TO ME, AT LEAST, THAT WE
HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION THAT IS
LARGELY INCOMPETENT AND WHOSE
INCOMPETENCE AND RECKLESSNESS
HAVE THREATENED THE LIVES OF
MANY, MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTRY.
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF WHAT IN MY
VIEW WE MUST DO TO RESPOND TO
THIS CRISIS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, WE ARE
DEALING WITH A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES MUST
UNDERSTAND THAT AND DECLARE THAT
EMERGENCY.
NEXT, IF PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
UNWILLING OR UNABLE TO
LEADSELFLESSLY, WE MUST
IMMEDIATELY CONVENE AN EMERGENCY
BIPARTISAN AUTHORITY OF EXPERTS
TO SUPPORT AND DIRECT THE
RESPONSE THAT IS COMPREHENSIVE,
COMPASSIONATE AND BASED FIRST
AND FOREMOST ON SCIENCE AND
FACT.
IN OTHER WORDS, CONGRESS, IN A
BIPARTISAN MANNER, MUST TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ADDRESSING
THIS UNPARALLELED CRISIS.
FURTHER, WE MUST AGGRESSIVELY
MAKE CERTAINED THAT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND PUBLIC SECTOR ARE
COOPERATING WITH EACH OTHER AND
WE NEED NATIONAL AND STATE
HOTLINES STAFFED WITH
WELL-TRAINED PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
BEST INFORMATION AVAILABLE.
ONE OF THE ASPECTS OF THE
CURRENT CRISIS IS THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ASKING US WHAT
ARE THE SYMPTOMS OF CORONAVIRUS?
DO I HAVE A COLD?
DO I HAVE THE FLU?
I DO HAVE THE CORONAVIRUS?
WHO IS GOING TO HELP ME?
WHERE DO I GO TO SEEK MEDICAL
TREATMENT?
HOW DO I GET A TEST?
WHEN IS THAT TEST GOING TO BE
PROCESSED?
PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS,
AND AT THE STATEWIDE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL, WE NEED EXPERTS TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION TO OUR PEOPLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
TRANSPARENCY, SOMETHING THAT THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION HAS
FOUGHT DAY AFTER DAY TO STIFLE.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
OUR COUNTRY, IN OUR STATES AND,
IN FACT, ALL OVER THE WORLD.
IF THERE WAS EVER A TIME FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND HONESTY AND
BEING STRAIGHTFORWARD THIS IS
THAT MOMENT.
AND WE NEED THAT INFORMATION
COMING FROM CREDIBLE, RESPECTED,
SCIENTIFIC VOICES OF WHICH WE
HAVE MANY IN OUR OWN COUNTRY AND
ALL OVER THIS WORLD, NOT FROM
POLITICIANS.
AND DURING A CRISIS, WE MUST
MAKE SURE THAT WE CARE FOR THE
COMMUNITIES MOST VULNERABLE TO
THE HEALTH AND ECONOMIC PAIN
THAT IS COMING.
THOSE IN NURSING HOMES AND
REHABILITATION FACILITIES.
THOSE CONFINED IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CENTERS, THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED AND IN
JAILS.
AND ALL PEOPLE, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
UNFORTUNATELY, AS I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE INCREASINGLY
UNDERSTAND, OUR COUNTRY IS AT A
SEVERE DISADVANTAGE COMPARED TO
EVERY OTHER MAJOR COUNTRY ON
EARTH BECAUSE WE DO NOT DID
GUARANTEE HEALTHCARE TO ALL
PEOPLE AS A RIGHT AND AS WE
SPEAK SOME 87 MILLION AMERICANS
ARE EITHER UNINSURED OR UNDER
ININSURED.
WHEN YOU ARE UNINSURED OR UNDER
INSURED YOU HESITATE ABOUT
GETTING THE MEDICAL CARE YOU
NEED BECAUSE YOU CANNOT AFFORD
TO GET THAT MEDICAL CARE.
THE RESULT IS MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
CANNOT AFFORD TO GO TO THE
DOCTOR LET ALONE PAY FOR
CORONAVIRUS TEST.
WHILE WE WORK TO PASS A MEDICARE
FOR ALL SINGLE PAIR SYSTEM, THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT TODAY
MUST MAKE IT CLEAR THAT IN THE
MIDST OF THIS EMERGENCY,
EVERYONE IN OUR COUNTRY,
REGARDLESS OF INCOME, OR WHERE
THEY LIVE MUST BE ABLE TO GET
ALL OF THE HEALTHCARE THEY NEED
WITHOUT COST.
OBVIOUSLY, WHEN A VACCINE OR
OTHER EFFECTIVE TREATMENT IS
DEVELOPED, IT MUST BE FREE OF
CHARGE.
WE CANNOT LIVE IN A NATION WHERE
IF YOU HAVE THE MONEY YOU GET
THE TREATMENT YOU NEED TO
SURVIVE BUT IF YOU ARE WORKING
CLASS, OR POOR, YOU GET TO THE
END OF THE LINE.
THAT WOULD BE MORALLY
UNACCEPTABLE.
FURTHER, WE NEED EMERGENCY
FUNDING RIGHT NOW FOR PAID
FAMILY AND MEDICAL LEAVE.
ANYONE WHO IS SICK, SHOULD BE
ABLE TO STAY HOME DURING THIS
EMERGENCY AND RECEIVE THEIR
PAYCHECK.
WHAT WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE IS AT
A TIME WHEN HALF OF OUR PEOPLE
ARE LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK,
WHEN THEY NEED TO GO TO WORK IN
ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILY, WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE
PEOPLE GOING TO WORK WHO ARE
SICK AND WHO CAN SPREAD THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WE ALSO NEED AN IMMEDIATE
EXPANSION OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS IN THIS COUNTRY SO THAT
EVERY AMERICAN WILL HAVE ACCESS
TO A NEARBY HEALTHCARE FACILITY.
WHERE DO I GO?
HOW DO I GET A TEST?
HOW DO I GET THE RESULTS OF THAT
TEST?
NEED GREATLY TO EXPAND OUR
PRIMARY HEALTHCARE CAPABILITIES
IN THIS COUNTRY AND THAT
INCLUDES EXPANDING COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS.
WE NEED TO DETERMINE THE STATUS
OF OUR TESTING AND PROCESSING
FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
THE GOVERNMENT MUST RESPOND
AGGRESSIVELY TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT WE, IN FACT, HAVE THE
LATEST AND MOST EFFECTIVE TEST
AVAILABLE AND THE QUICKEST MEANS
OF PROCESSING THOSE TESTS.
THERE ARE OTHER COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD WHO ARE DOING BETTER
THAN WE ARE IN THAT REGARD.
WE SHOULD BE LEARNING FROM THEM.
NO ONE, NONE OF THE MEDICAL
EXPERTS THAT I HAVE TALKED TO
DISPUTE THAT THERE IS A MAJOR
SHORTAGE OF ICU UNITS AND
VENTILATORS THAT ARE NEEDED TO
RESPOND TO THIS CRISIS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MUST WORK
AGGRESSIVELY WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
EQUIPMENT IS AVAILABLE TO
HOSPITALS AND THE REST OF THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY.
OUR CURRENT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
DOES NOT HAVE THE DOCTORS AND
NURSES WE CURRENTLY NEED.
WE ARE UNDER STAFFED.
DURING THIS CRISIS, WE NEED TO
MOBILIZE MEDICAL RESIDENTS,
RETIRED MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
AND OTHER MEDICAL PERSONNEL TO
HELP US DEAL WITH THIS CRISIS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOCTORS, NURSES AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS HAVE THE
INSTRUCTIONS AND PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
NEED.
THIS IS NOT ONLY BECAUSE WE CARE
ABOUT THE WELL-BEING OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS, BUT IF THEY GO
DOWN, THEN OUR CAPABILITY TO
RESPOND TO THIS CRISIS IS
SIGNIFICANTLY DIMINISHED.
THE PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY MUST
BE TOLD IN NO UNCERTAIN TERMS
THAT THE MEDICINES THAT THEY
MANUFACTURE FOR THIS CRISIS WILL
BE SOLD AT COST THIS IS NOT THE
TIME FOR PRICE GOUGING OR
PROFITEERING.
THE CORONAVIRUS IS ALREADY
CAUSING A GLOBAL ECONOMIC
MELTDOWN WHICH IS IMPACTING
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AND
IN OUR OWN COUNTRY AND IT IS
ESPECIALLY DANGEROUS FOR LOW
INCOME AND WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES, PEOPLE WHO TODAY
BEFORE THE CRISIS ARE STRUGGLING
ECONOMICALLY.
INSTEAD OF PROVIDING MORE TAX
BREAKS TO THE TOP 1% AND LARGE
CORPORATIONS, WOULD HE NEED TO
PROVIDE ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE TO
THE ELDERLY, AND I WORRY VERY
MUCH ABOUT ELDERLY PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY TODAY, MANY OF WHOM
ARE ISOLATED, MANY OF WHOM DO
NOT HAVE A LOT OF MONEY.
WE NEED TO WOERB WORRY ABOUT THO
ARE ALREADY SICK.
WE NEED TO WORRY ABOUT WORKING
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN, PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES, THE HOMELESS
AND ALL THOSE WHO ARE
VULNERABLE.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE IN THAT
CONTEXT EMERGENCY UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE TO ANYONE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO LOSES THEIR JOB
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
RIGHT NOW 23% OF THOSE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE EMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION DO NOT RECEIVE IT.
UNDER OUR PROPOSAL EVERYONE WHO
LOSES A JOB MUST QUALIFY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION AT
LEAST 100 PERCENT OF THEIR PRIOR
SALARY WITH A CAP OF $1,150 A
WEEK OR $60,000 A YEAR.
IN ADDITION, THOSE WHO DEPEND ON
TIPS, IN THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY
IS SUFFERING VERY MUCH FROM THE
MELTDOWN, THOSE WHO DEPEND ON
TIPS GIVE WORKERS, DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS MUST ALSO QUALIFY
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO
MAKE UP FOR THE INCOME THAT THEY
LOSE DURING THIS CRISIS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ELDERLY, PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES, AND FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO
NUTRITIOUS FOOD.
THAT MEANS EXPANDING THE MEALS
ON WHEELS PROGRAM.
IT MEANS EXPANDING THE SCHOOL
LUNCH PROGRAM AND SNAP, SO THAT
NO ONE GOES HUNGRY DURING THIS
CRISIS AND EVERYONE WHO CANNOT
LEAVE THEIR HOME CAN RECEIVE
NUTRITIOUS MEALS DELIVERED
DIRECTLY TO WHERE THEY LIVE.
WE NEED ALSO IN THIS ECONOMIC
CRISIS TO PLACE AN IMMEDIATE
MORATORIUM ON EVICTIONS, ON
FORECLOSURES, AND ON UTILITY SO
NO ONE LOSES THEIR HOME DURING
THIS CRISIS AND THAT EVERYONE
HAS ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER,
ELECTRICITY, HEAT, AND
AIRCONDITIONING.
WE NEED TO CONSTRUCT EMERGENCY
HOMELESS SHELTERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE HOMELESS SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND COLLEGE
STUDENTS QUARANTINED OFF CAMPUS
ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE THE SHELTER,
THE HEALTHCARE, AND THE
NUTRITION THEY NEED.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
LENDING TO SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZE
BUSINESSES TO COVER PAYROLL, NEW
CONSTRUCTION OF MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES, AND PRODUCTION OF
EMERGENCY SUPPLIES SUCH AS MASKS
AND VENTILATORS, A VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IN THE MIDST
OF THIS CRISIS.
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE, AND
THAT BOTTOM LINE IS THAT IN THE
MIDST OF THIS UNPRECEDENTED
MOMENT, WE NEED TO LISTEN TO THE
SCIENTISTS, TO THE RESEARCHERS,
TO THE MEDICAL FOLKS NOT THE
POLITICIANS.
WE NEED AN EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO
THE CURRENT EMERGENCY AND WE
NEED IT IMMEDIATELY.
WE NEED MORE DOCTORS AND NURSES
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WORKERS WHO LOSE THEIR JOBS IN
THIS CRISIS RECEIVE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE THEY
NEED AND IN THIS MOMENT, IN THIS
MOMENT, WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN THE FUTURE AFTER THIS
CRISIS IS BEHIND US, WE BUILD A
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT MAKES
SURE THAT EVERY PERSON IN THIS
COUNTRY IS GUARANTEED THE
HEALTHCARE THAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.